avec vous martin à la réunion notre
rendez vous médical de la semaine donc
et ce soir je lui ai dit en commençant
journal vous avez choisi de nous parler
de la couche port pour ça vous allez
nous montrer un petit film un petit film
dans lequel il on trouve certaines
images assez impressionnante
oui c'est en réalité allons film danger
extrait quatre accouchements qui se sont
passés dans la même clinique et qui je
crois témoignage fort bien des sept cent
mille naissances qui ont lieu
actuellement en france de nos jours
c'est de la garder j'aimerais bien à me
pousser plus et plus la peine qui
reviennent tous rien de bien ce qui se
passe et gardien
[Musique]
elle est hantée qui se voit là une jambe
d'heure est là il faut y aller non-stop
[Musique]
apprenez tout
vous avez soufflé un bonbon en un grand
coderre et je vous adore la vous pousser
tant que vous pouvez voilà pas trop fort
regardez le bien voilà la fille c'est
bien une fille tiens on la paye
voilà elle est toute belle
faire
il ya beaucoup tué
[Musique]
la caméra pouvait voir la série car il
est riche à cet égard sont les chats à
la gironde
[Musique]
et très bas rhin sont permis mais voici
un quatrième accouchement celui ci est
dit sans violence la mère a choisi
d'accoucher sans bruit sans lumière
forte dans la pénombre et la douceur
dans une atmosphère feutrée que la
caméra est parvenu difficilement à
saisir ce mode d'accouchement fait
l'objet de controverses nombreuses
controverses mais city mieux le problème
aujourd'hui car au delà de la sécurité
on exige maintenant du confort pour la
mère et pour l'enfant
ce dernier bébé à sa licence se porte
bien mais on ne veut pas qu'ils soient
traumatisés par l'événement brutale de
sa naissance de sa séparation d'avec là
mère il est plongé dans l'eau tiède dans
une eau douce qui doit en principe lui
rappeler le milieu d'anti bien partie
pour voir ce document avec des images
effectivement impressionnants avant de
poursuivre une petite précision parce
que nous l'avons indiqué sur l'écran
anesthésie péridurale
oui oui expliqué oui bien sûr il s'agit
d'un stg la femme
localement c'est à dire sur le bas du
corps et non pas le haut ce que n'a pas
dit c'était une césarienne
autrement dit la femme et le ventre
ouvert et pourrait exister en direct à
la naissance mans alors si je pense que
c'est même un progrès la médecine est un
progrès intéressants
alors vous avez vu là dans une même
clinique quatre accouchements très
différent et je voudrais insister sur la
naissance 178 il y avait un débat après
ce film qui était présenté récemment ou
publiques à la presse au médecin où il y
avait plein de partenaires j'allais dire
des parents des sages-femmes les
psychologues des obstétriciens et vont
insister sur deux notions qui sont je
crois les les deux notions que les
années 178 le confort et la sécurité et
tout le débat et confort ou sécurité
confort et sécurité car vous l'avez vu à
coucher dans le noir personne ne peut
dire si c'est mieux ou pas pour l'enfant
mais certains
pense que c'est la frette être mauvais
pendant plomb en revanche on peut aussi
dire que trop de lumière est mauvais
pour l'enfant en revanche vous avez vu
que actuellement une césarienne et plus
rien qu'un accouchement par le siège
c'est-à-dire quand l'enfant arrive les
pieds le premier est plus un problème
alors comme on a vu tout ça je crois
qu'il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
l'accouchement se taper un accouchement
à la carte qu'on a le droit à
différentes salles d'accouchement mais
qu'il ne faut pas aller trop loin en
disant j'exige ceci tard parfois le
médecin fait mieux que la femme ce qui
est bon pour elle ce qui est bon pour
l'enfant ou bon pour la société
et puis je crois qu'on 78 700 mille
naissances se passe fournir merci martin